monsieur leroy passionné par l'énergie
du vent il a imaginé ce moyen pour
recharger le moteur électrique qui est
un hymne chats 2 il a acheté le véhicule
il y a trois ans a remplacé le moteur à
explosion par un moteur électrique de 72
vols à l'intérieur six batteries d'un
poids total de 100 kg fournit 60 vols
tsoup 56 ans perd à partir de 20
km/heure lévis entre en mouvement
fournit de l'énergie et recharge
partiellement les ags monsieur leroi
peut passer devant les pompes à essence
sans s'arrêter
la recharge des batteries lui coûte 30
centimes son invention suscite de la
part des sedanais beaucoup de curiosité
alors y'a pas beaucoup l'ensemble
l'intensité puisqu'il ya 46 ans en faire
qui renverront serait tranquille en
terre
j'en vois toi y en a 18 122 chevaux et
l'essec
alors pour les servitudes ça marche
aussi c'est à dire l'éclairage tout ça
et ça absorbe l'énergie émise est
spécial pour l'éclairage
monsieur leroy a conservé les vitesses
mais a supprimé l'accélérateur
à l'intérieur un ampèremètre lui permet
de contrôler sa consommation d'énergie
le service des mines après quatre
examens a homologué le véhicule monsieur
leroy a dû mettre un grillage protecteur
est équipé l'engin de phares et de feux
de gabarit les avantages silence de
fonctionnement
pas de pollution le secours de l'hélice
pour recharger inconvénients l'autonomie
n'est que de 40 km à 40 à l'heure la
question est de savoir ce qui manque
pour que le véhicule accumule autant
d'énergie qu'il en consomme un
alternateur qui les améliorer l'énergie
électrique
il pourrait retrouver un alternateur de
70 vols qui ne devrait au moins 41 de
manière avant au moins trois à quatre
kilomètres qui ferait environ 400
chevaux
actuellement la batture faire environ 35
heures 35 à 40 à l'heure mais comme pas
assez vite il faudrait qu'elle monte à
50 à l'heure où la barre du coup le
rendement des génératrices actuelle et
augmenter la puissance du moteur d'un
cheval et pour que vera choix en attaque
pour trouver des moteurs actuels d'un
soldes sur 2000 voici pas facile à
trouver et vous espérer y arriver
bientôt
c'est un ami il demande aux retraités je
fais ça pour m'amuser et je l'espère
améliorer la batture 2
et puis jean en plus alors combien de
temps bientôt compter un longue pour
passer